la tournée française du cabaret new
burlesque et grâce au film de mathieu
amalric primé à cannes les pulpeuses
effeuilleuses sont de retour sur scène
strip tease paillettes et s'attire de
l'amérique marie-hélène bono frédéric
bazille elles s'appellent mimi keaton
d'ortie ou july
souvenez-vous le festival de cannes
elles ont affolé la croisette avec le
film de mathieu amalric tournée film qui
a reçu le prix de la mise en scène
depuis leurs spectacles connaît un
succès fou en france
préparatifs de dernière minute avant
d'entrer en scène
les jeunes femmes sont un peu stressés
c'est que je suis très en retard si elle
fonda street is ce n'est pas tellement
pour la dimension érotique mais plutôt
pour le côté parodique des numéros ces
femmes n'hésitent pas à montrer leur
corps surtout pour s'amuser un corps pas
toujours aux normes des canons actuels
de la beauté tout y est porte
jarretelles plumes paillettes corsé mais
aussi parfois poésie
[Musique]
mais le film n'a pas changé grand chose
pour moi c'est le public français qui a
changé il a compris notre univers du
nord
oui
[Musique]
on était surtout connu dans les
festivals on a de la chance
le film tourné a fait connaître la joie
du bernet il y a quand même un homme
dans la troupe rocky roulette avec un
strip tease aussi déjanté que débridé le
seul homme dans ce monde de femmes
[Musique]
c'est très difficile vous savez ce sont
des ferrailleurs women est les femmes
sont difficiles de photos mais ce sont
les plus belles choses du monde a faim
non je plaisante
c'est bien c'est très agréable d'esprit
bref une troupe qui ne se prend pas au
sérieux et un spectacle à déguster sans
arrière-pensée
[Musique]